- In 2016, a spooky white figure
with wide, unblinking eyes
was spotted wandering a Green
Bay, Wisconsin parking lot
at two in the morning.
Residents posted about
their sightings on Facebook
and made calls to the police.
But the strange figure
continued appearing that night,
in a local park and under an overpass,
then, it suddenly disappeared
just as mysteriously.
A week later, a similar being
appeared in South Carolina,
beckoning to residents from the woods.
Over the next two months, dozens
of these mysterious figures
would pop up all across
the U.S. and Canada,
along with sightings in 16 other
countries around the world.
Some would attempt to approach
children to frighten them,
most appeared silently, watching,
but all of them were dressed as clowns.
Clowns are known for their
humorous antics, balloon animals,
and juggling to amuse audiences,
whether they're teaching
us how to tell time on Saturday morning TV
or selling us french fries.
So when did these silly, funny staples
of our childhoods become monsters?
(adventurous music)
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
The history of clowns spans centuries.
We associate them with
bright-colored clothing,
oddly shaped hats, oversized
shoes, and painted faces.
Our current image of
clowns started taking shape
around the mid-19th century
when an English comedian and
actor named Joseph Grimaldi
began performing in a
polka-dotted costume,
pointy, triangular wig, ruffled collar,
and red-and-white face paint.
But since the 1980s,
clowns have taken a decidedly dark turn.
Depictions of clowns have
taken these visual traits
from kooky to creepy
by playing up features
like pale skin, big eyes,
and a wide unnerving smile.
(clown laughs menacingly)
These creepy clowns appear
like the silly characters
of our childhoods, just slightly off.
So why the shift?
Even before killer clowns
were all over our screens,
clown characters have occupied
an unusual place in the social order.
Some of the most ancient
versions were fairly problematic.
In places like ancient Egypt and Rome,
stigmatized, marginalized
people, many enslaved,
were treated as entertainment
at parties and events for the wealthy.
Ancient Rome also had mime-type characters
and ones who performed
unusual body stunts.
Beginning at least as
early as the 13th century,
Chinese opera featured clown
characters called Chou,
who were often the only ones on stage
allowed to improvise lines.
And Renaissance-era
court jesters in Europe
were kept in noble
circles as entertainment
and were permitted to satirize royalty
and speak truths without
fearing punishment.
Clowns throughout the world
began as trickster characters
who had a pass to flout social conventions
and behave in transgressive ways.
By the mid 1800s, clowns began to filter
from their high-class
entertainment origins
into popular culture.
Joseph Grimaldi became a celebrity
in the English theater scene.
Meanwhile, in the U.S.,
the Ringling Brothers
and Barnum & Bailey set up circus shows
featuring clowns performing
slapstick comedy routines.
As clowns rose in popularity,
they retained their roguish spirit.
It wasn't until literary works
like Charles Dickens' "Pickwick Papers,"
Edgar Allan Poe's "Hop-Frog"
and Ruggero Leoncavallo's
opera "Pagliacci,"
that the clown persona
took on a much darker tone.
These depictions were some of the first
to look at the man behind the mask.
Depicting clowns that, underneath
their trickster silliness,
have sinister or even
murderous intentions.
(Pagliacci singing in Italian)
But by the mid-20th century,
American clowns got a
kid-friendly makeover
featuring more friendly figures
like "Howdy Doody's" Clarabell the Clown,
Bozo the Clown, and Ronald McDonald.
This reflected the broad optimism
and prosperity of the post-war era.
But this wholesome imagining
of the clown didn't last long.
In 1979, serial killer John Wayne Gacy,
who worked as a party clown
as a day job, was arrested.
At the same time, the
Satanic Panic of the 1980s
was picking up speed.
This moral frenzy based
on conspiracy theories
that evil cultists were harming children
made many people anxious
about who they could trust.
Against this cultural backdrop,
creepy clowns started to
become a pop culture staple,
often using their
kid-friendly cultural status
to lure children to their deaths.
Their exaggerated facial features
pushed clowns into the uncanny valley,
a theorized point where
an object or character
appears almost like a real person
without looking fully human.
It's that tiny bit of dissonance
which fills actual human
viewers with unease.
Film depictions use this creepy dissonance
to create frightening characters.
"Poltergeist," a movie in
which a possessed clown toy
attacks a young boy in his
bedroom, was a box office hit.
And "Batman" starred horror
movie staple Jack Nicholson
playing Joker as a villainous clown.
Even children's media turned
clowns exclusively scary.
Who else has nightmares
about the evil firefighter clown
from "Brave Little Toaster?"
'Cause I hate it.
Perhaps most famously,
Stephen King's 1986 novel "It"
features Pennywise, an evil
clown that stalks the suburbs
looking for children to frighten and kill.
The book became so successful
that it was adapted as a TV
series by the end of the decade,
solidifying the clown as not
just a man in face paint,
but a monster that could transform
into whatever you fear most.
The 1988 cult sci-fi horror comedy
"Killer Klowns from Outer Space"
turned this newly-minted
archetype on its head
with a more playful
take on the killer clown
featuring murderous
aliens disguised as clowns
who trap their unsuspecting
victims in cotton candy cocoons.
The film's decision to steer
the killer clown archetype
back towards its whimsical origins
shows how prevalent the creepy
clown phenomenon had become.
The last decade has brought in
another wave of creepy
clowns in pop culture.
Horrifying harlequins cropped up
in "American Horror Stories,"
"Supernatural," and "Zombieland."
- [Columbus] Time to nut up or shut up.
(clown growls)
- "It, "The Joker," and "Poltergeist"
all got darker, grittier reboots,
but then, the clowns we
love to fear on screen
got a lot less fictional.
In the fall of 2016,
that mysterious clown
appeared in Wisconsin.
It didn't hurt anyone.
It just broke social norms,
as clowns have always done.
By creeping around at odd hours
and remaining silent when spoken to,
this clown didn't act quite human.
The prankster eventually revealed
that he was trying to drum up publicity
for an independent horror
film, and it worked.
Photos and stories about
the clown sightings
went viral on Facebook, inspiring
a wave of copycat clowns
in more than 20 states
over the next two months.
If you remember the late summer of 2016,
you know that it was a volatile
and politically divisive time.
It's possible that these tricksters wanted
to let off some of the tension
that was building in their communities
or to direct anxieties at
a common fictional enemy.
But they successfully tapped
into the public's fear
of these uncanny valley creatures enough
that some school districts
and municipalities
warned against, or even
banned, wearing clown costumes
at Halloween for being symbols of terror.
Police in Utah even received calls
about whether citizens were allowed
to shoot clowns on sight.
And when rumors started circulating
about a clown on Penn
State's campus that October,
more than 500 students took to the streets
in a so-called clown riot
to hunt the jester down.
And yet, just like in the '80s,
clowns were more of a psychological threat
than a physical one.
With their exaggerated
smiles, it's difficult
to read what clowns are
really thinking or feeling
underneath all that face paint
and their reputation
for mischievous behavior
makes it hard for us to predict
what they might do next.
And all of that uncertainty
makes us uneasy.
It's no wonder that killer clowns
tend to emerge in pop culture
at times of heightened political tension
or distrust in the social contract.
When we're all wondering
whether we can trust the people around us.
Clowns may be a symbol of human duality,
one that asks us to consider
if we all wear a little bit of a costume
when we present ourselves to the world.
Ruggero Leoncavallo's opera "Pavliacci."
- [Producer] "Pagliacci."
- "Pagliacci."
There's no V?
- [Producer] Wait there's...
Oh!
- "Pavliacci?"
- [Producer] I didn't even pick that up.
- Did I say it right though?
You're like, "Uh..."